how much time do you spend in westeros
these days
well you know that's an interesting
question that really varies and it
depends on
what i'm doing but
when i am actively writing
um when it's really going well and it
doesn't always go well by any means
there are good days and bad days there
are good months and bad months but
when it's going well i
live in westeros i i fall through the
computer i i wake up thinking of you
know tyrion and arya and and uh or aegon
the conqueror or whoever i'm writing
about and uh i go to sleep at night
thinking about them and
when i'm driving around i think about
them and it just fills my life
but in order to achieve this almost uh i
don't know zen state of uh obsession
i have to push away real life uh-huh
there are other writers who i know like
write four pages a day they write in
hotels they run on airplanes they write
everywhere i've never been one of those
writers i need to completely separate
yeah i need to be have the whole day
just to write nothing else on my
calendar
and it's a odd
irony that the the the very success of
game of thrones and a song of ice and
fire the popularity's books
has
made it harder for me to write these
books because the number of
interruptions distractions and other
things have increased uh you know
doubled and tripled and increased
tenfold and 100 fold right because
essentially what you're saying is when
you spend days
you know for example doing interviews
with nerdy podcasts that's right you're
not able to write that's right i'm not
writing today i'm here in chicago yeah
when i'm back home in santa fe i i will
be pushing everything and and writing uh
yes and i know some of my readers and uh
fans are very impatient about that they
wish i was
like the other writers who you know like
stephen king who i talked to once on a
show we did together about this very
thing and he's one of those guys who
writes six pages a day yeah come hell or
hide water or his cat just got run over
or whatever happens stephen king writes
his six pages a day i wish i could be
like that yeah i can't i can't how are
you managing
fan expectations these days i don't
think i do manage them what do you mean
by that i've learned to live with them
uh-huh i mean you know for most of my
career now a lot of people just know me
from a game of thrones a song of ice and
fire
but uh the first book that came out in
1996 well i published my first story in
1971. so i was already a
well-established author i'd written a
half dozen novels i'd written
60 70 80 short stories
i'd won awards i was pretty well
established yeah
but in those days and in that stage of
my career i worked largely in anonymity
uh in fact on many of my novels i didn't
even tell my agents that was working on
it a lot of writers work on a basis of
uh
they write three sample chapters and
outline and they sell the book and then
they're given a deadline for it i never
liked that model because
you know i was never good with deadlines
even even when i was a student at mcdill
up here in in evanston
graduate school yeah deadlines i didn't
take you know when they that's a medal f
there do you want to go into magazine or
newspaper
you know i said uh
newspaper deadlines every day no i don't
think i'll go for a magazine give you a
little more time monthly magazine you
know give me a little time to finish the
article that would be better
so i never sold my novels that way i
would start to work on a novel and
then when it was finished i would call
up my agent and say oh look i finished
it
you're welcome please go sell it for me
and they would that's great but when i i
started a song of ice and fire yeah and
the books came out and
they became increasingly popular largely
through word of mouth you know each one
doing better than the last and and
building up a certain amount of momentum
suddenly
people began anticipating the next one
and for the first time i got ripples of
uh
well when is necron coming out or why
isn't it coming out this year this other
writer over here he publishes a book
every year yeah well i'm not that other
writer i'm i've always been slow yeah i
mean i have people who who
started 20 years after me who have like
40 novels in brenton right right like
10.
and it just increased as as the
series became more and more popular of
course
and i i had this not a blog which i
started you know i was like the last
person in the world i started blogging
when everybody else had stopped blogging
and switched to twitter i'm always a
little behind the curve here you know
um
and i tried to explain
i figured the fans would well i'm i'm
working on it guys don't worry it'll
come out eventually i thought that would
do it but it didn't do it it was like i
did it for some people i think once
again you know yeah i get 100 people
saying take as long as you want no
problem
but for some it was just throwing
gasoline on the fire well that's not an
explanation what are you doing why are
you you should be home writing you know
why are you doing anything
and at a certain point i
i gave up trying to manage fan
expectations i just said well
you know i'm writing it
it'll be done when it's done
um i
some days i have good days and i write
five
six pages that's a great day for me
some days i struggle
and you know barely get half a page done
some days i go in and i look at what i
wrote last week and say
this is all terrible and i rip it up and
start it all over again so that has me
wondering i mean i think we're at such a
fascinating time of fandom right i mean
speaking of nerdery
i think
especially makers are facing so much
pressure from their fans in a way that
they didn't before simply because of the
internet right it's like people can
tweet at you all the time
and i wonder like in some ways i think
that's a really beautiful thing i think
it's really exciting that people love
something enough to have that much
passion and that many strong opinions
about it but i imagine
for a guy like you that can also be
really frustrating
yeah it can be i mean i i think like
like most writers and i think this is
true of uh
the vast majority of writers and
probably a lot of
artists of other sorts too
you know um
we like praise and it you know we absorb
it eerily like sponges but then in one
sense it slides off off our back
and we hate criticism so you know i can
get a hundred good reviews and people
saying great we love you go on one guy
who's snarking at me and i'll
yeah obsessed
yeah that bad review i call that picking
a scab in my brain you know right that's
right
and you know i admit to that at least
there's a lot of writers who pray oh no
bad reviews don't bother me
it does bother them
i know their secrets behind closed doors
so
you know there are good things about the
internet certainly and and like
everybody else living in 21st century
america i'm i'm addicted to it but
like many addictions i don't think it's
necessarily good for you
and there are there are
what i think is really bad things about
the internet and i'm not just talking
let me make this very clear here because
i've given other interviews where i've
made general statements about the
internet and and then it gets picked up
on on sure
websites and made as if i'm talking
directly about my fans or responses to
ice and fire yeah i'm talking about
just the way it is everything kind of
discourse on the internet there's
there's a horrible
level of of negativity and attacks
twitter mobs
and uh
abusive language and things are so and
it's it's
it's empowered by the anonymity that
people can be anonymous or people can
hide behind some some false thing and
nobody would come up to you and say some
of the things that people write on
twitter they'd get punched in the nose
or they'd have to take responsibility
for comments but
it empowers cowardice you can you can
attack people you can say horrible
things you you can say
racist things misogynist things
whatever you want uh and and hide behind
some false name and even if you get
banned from twitter
then you pop up the next day with
another new pseudonym um
and also the whole
structure of it where how many
characters is it like 140 it used to be
140 they expanded it now it's too many
you can pretty much say whatever you
want
[Laughter]
it's too many maybe but it's also not
enough i mean that's very true my main
vehicle for interacting with the
internet is still my blog
for the most part when i post there i
post long things that you know if it
written on a typewriter or thing would
be three four pages of thoughts or at
least a page several paragraphs i
develop arguments i
make jokes i do things and and i i can't
talk in
140 character bursts here yeah i mean
real discussion any kind of meaningful
dialogue between human beings is more
nuanced than that and there should be
some give and take and you should be
able to make
kindly fairly structured and complicated
arguments or discussions and
the internet takes that away from us
yeah i like to say
the odds of you actually being able to
change somebody's mind on twitter and
facebook are just like non-existent you
know like that's where people go to
double down
on whatever preconceived notions they
have and there's not a lot of wiggle
room around that